Let's go next to, uh, Oh, you know who we
haven't heard from from awhile? We haven't
heard from Milo for a little while. Milo from
the nine one, seven. What's going on, Milo?
Hey David, how you doing? Good. How are you?
Uh, pretty good. Uh, first I actually just
wanted to ask out of curiosity, cause I, uh,
I know you're Jewish. Are you fasting today
by any chance?
No, no, no, no.
Oh, okay. Yeah. Um, anyway, so, uh, my question
is, uh, more broadly speaking, it's about,
uh, pro worker policies. But to sort of contextualize
the question a little bit, I want to give
a quick anecdote. So about, uh, three months
ago that was on a trip to France with a few
family members and yeah, uh, on the, on the
way back, uh, we were in the airport in Paris
and I was waiting in line with my father and
he is like a sense, he was like a waffle the
centers kind of guy. And um, as soon as we
got, as we got closer to the line, so we were
waiting in line for about an hour and a half,
two hours. And as we got further towards the
front of the line, um, the reason why we realized
it was taking so long was because there were
only about a one or two TSA workers sitting
at the desk to help us check our baggage and
[inaudible].
Okay. Hold on. Can we back up as I hold? Can
we let me, let me, let's just back up a little
bit so I can understand the story. You're,
you're in Paris, this is happening in Paris,
right?
Yeah.
Okay. So you're saying that it's not, so TSA
doesn't check bags and they only are in the
U S are you talking about there were only
two airline employees checking people in?
Uh, yeah. Or just like the people who sit,
uh, you know, behind the desk, like towards
the end, the entrance to the airport where
we like check our baggage.
Okay. Got it. So this was, these were not
security people, these were airline employees
checking people in and checking bags?
Correct.
Got it. Okay. All right. And there were only
two of them until the lines moving really
slow. Very common, particularly in European
airports. Yes.
Yeah, yeah, yeah. Cause like the, the point
that my dad made was like under like a Bernie
presidency or whatever. Um, like, Oh, like
all of America would be like that because
like I think the point he was trying to make
was like when workers have more rights because
like France is a really pro worker country.
Bernie's a really pro worker guy. Like they
have more autonomy and they're more likely
to like spend their time in ways that are
like inconvenient to customers. So I'm just
curious like what's like your take on that?
I mean, uh, I don't know if you've noticed,
but it's not like American based airlines
are known for having particularly good service.
I'm less exposed to it because in the U S
between I'm never checking a bag and I have
TSA precheck so like I never deal with it.
But every time I go to Logan airport to fly
anywhere, the lines are just as outrageous.
So I don't know. I mean it just, it doesn't
seem to really compute for me. It doesn't
seem, you know, he's saying that's the, it's
like that in most of the world. I don't know
that, uh, yeah, it's just, it doesn't seem
like a very solid argument to me.
Yeah. All right. Oh yeah. It was just a phone
to see what your take was on that. So I appreciate
taking the call.
All right, Milo. Good to hear from you. Appreciate
the phone call.